[APPLAUSE]
All right, thank you, everybody.
Sorry for the slow start.
I have to have to say it's very
exciting to be back in Korea
again.
I was here in October, and
lots of developers we spoke to
were just waiting
for a Chrome WebView,
so I'm glad to be able
to bring it to you,
and show you what
this is all about.
OK, so what we
have now is we have
a new WebView in Android KitKat.
Of course, this WebView
is now built on Chrome,
or built on the
Chromium codebase,
and so today I'm going to cover
what the WebView is about,
what it means to
you as a developer,
explain some of the
debugging features that
are in the WebView,
and go through a few
of the differences
between the new WebView
and the old WebView.
So a very, very short kind of
summary is all these points.
What does it actually mean?
What does it mean to
you as a developer?
Not that many people
put their hands
up about using the
WebView here so,
can I have a show
of hands of people
who know what the
WebView is for?
You don't know what
the WebView is for?
All right, if you are building
an Android application,
the WebView is a component
that lets you use HTML, CSS,
and JavaScript as part
of your application.
So the idea being that you
can use web technology skills,
but in an application that
looks like a native Android
application.
And I'll slow down
at that point.
So what that means
is, if you want
to do cross-device
development-- if you want
to develop for other
operating systems
as well as Android-- you
can write your logic,
if it's a game or something
like that, in JavaScript.
And then you pull a
WebView in, and the WebView
takes care of rendering
to the screen.
So the actual browser that ships
in Android, the normal browser,
uses the WebView internally.
So Android, prior to KitKat,
relied on all the old WebView
for displaying web content.
So anytime you
went to a web page,
it was the WebView embedded
in that application displaying
there on the screen.
So what this means is
that from KitKat forward,
every single browser
that uses the WebView
uses the Chromium codebase.
And so what we
currently have in KitKat
is a snapshot of Chrome 30, OK?
So the WebView actually ships
with Android for every release,
and the current release is 30.
So the features in
Chromium version 30
are what you'll see
reflected in the WebView.
The difference between Chrome,
the browser, and Chrome WebView
is mainly in the
graphics back end.
It's all invisible to you
as an application developer,
but what has had to
be done is chop out
the back end of Chrome, the
browser, throw it in the bin,
replace it with a
graphics stack that
is compatible with the
Android operating system.
So Android developers here-- who
knows what SurfaceFlinger is?
Anyone?
One person, no people, OK.
Android graphic subsystem has a
whole lot of things internally.
There's SurfaceFlinger.
There's
hardware-accelerated layers.
There's a whole-view hierarchy.
And so we've taken
the Chrome codebase
and modified that
back end of drawing
to be compatible with
the Android hierarchy.
But as a web
developer, you probably
say, why does this even matter?
Well, in the olden days, this
is what we had in the WebView.
So the original WebView, from
Android 4.3, 4.2, backwards
all the way to 2.3,
scored very badly
on HTML5 features and testing.
So it's got 284 out of
555, so not very good.
In the last two to
three years, there's
been a huge, huge acceleration
in HTML5 technology,
in both APIs and features.
And the result is that
web developers who
want to use these
features in apps
are asking for
new functionality.
So now with the
KitKat WebView, we
do a much more respectable 424.
So what this means is
that it's very easy
to take logic that might
be in a mobile website
and translate it across
into a native application
that you can then
publish on the Play Store
and make money, which
is always important.
All right, so what
are the new features?
So here are some of the
features that we actually
have in the WebView that
weren't there in the old days.
So IndexedDB-- that's a
very important technology
to store data on the device.
Now, IndexedDB provides a really
powerful database primitive.
It runs asynchronously, so
it's a non-blocking API.
So for example, if you
build an HTML5 game,
you may want to
store lots of gaming
levels in your application.
So you can actually
use IndexedDB
as the storage mechanism
for those games.
WebSockets is a really,
really good one.
WebSockets allows a client
application to talk directly
to a server over a socket,
very similar to a TCP
socket in normal networking.
So this means, instead of
having to do the whole response
type of thing, you can actually
push messages both directions--
from client to
server, and reverse.
Very, very important technology.
RequestAnimationFrame is
a very, very new-- well,
newish-- technology.
What requestAnimationFrame
is is,
it's a callback into JavaScript.
And what happens there is
that every time the browser,
or in this case, the WebView,
wants to redraw a frame,
it calls back into
requestAnimationFrame.
Now, the reason this is
useful is for animations.
So you can synchronize
your animations
on screen exactly to the
refresh rate of the application,
so you don't waste time.
So in JavaScript,
it's very common
to animate by just setting a
timer, and redrawing every time
the timer ticks.
The problem with doing
that is that you either
draw too little or too
much, because you're not
synchronized to
the actual screen.
So requestAnimationFrame
does that.
It synchronizes for you.
Also, there are SVG
filters and effects.
So with the new WebView,
we have a whole lot
of different filters, like
sepia, convolution blurs,
all sorts of different
filters that you can then
apply to any HTML content.
And probably the
single-most important one
in the Chrome WebView is
the hardware acceleration.
So the WebView itself is
now hardware-accelerated.
The rendering in the
view goes a lot faster
than the old WebView.
There are compatibility
differences,
which I'll talk about soon,
but the most important thing
is that Android is
shifting to hardware
acceleration for everything.
So the default for
all new applications
is hardware-accelerated
on, and the WebView
takes advantage of that.
So if you turn hardware
acceleration off,
you will have a very badly
degraded performance.
So there are a lot
more features in HTML5,
but probably the most
important feature of all
is the debugging features.
Now, in the old days
of the old WebView,
it was very, very
difficult to debug content.
And the new Chromium WebView
brings in the ability
to use Chrome and all of
Chrome's DevTools to debug.
And so we see this
little bit of code.
That's all the code you need
to add to your application
to enable debugging.
So I just want to do a quick
demo of what this means.
OK, I have a phone here.
And so as you can see, I've
got some applications running.
So I've got this application
here that I've built.
Now, this application is
written using a WebView.
It's a little rolling ball game.
You can see the little chrome
ball rolling around there.
So if we go back to my
browser, wherever it's gone.
Where has it gone?
Right, so if I just
open up a new tab,
if I type in this
address, Chrome:inspect,
and plug my phone in via
USB, what I find is that all
of a sudden, the browser has
actually seen my phone that
it's plugged in to the laptop.
So this is just simply a USB
cable connected to my phone.
To do this, we don't have to
install any special software.
There's no development
kit or anything.
It's a standard
part of Chrome now.
If you'll see, I have
this little inspect link,
and that little rectangle
there, the gray rectangle,
is the WebView
running on my phone.
So if I just click on inspect,
it pulls up Chrome DevTools.
So just [INAUDIBLE].
So if I go out of
projection mode,
and I'll try and find
my little window here,
you'll see that what
we actually have is
we have the Chrome DevTools
actually showing me
the content that's
running in the view.
So for example, if I mouse
over things in the HTML here,
you actually see
that it's displaying
what's actually on the phone.
All right, so as I hover
over, see the wall there
that's gone blue at the top?
That's actually a
div in HTML markup,
so all of these different walls
in the game are actually divs.
So you'll see as we roll over
them, we can actually see them.
Now, what's interesting
about this particular example
is that it's using some
of the new HTML5 APIs.
So it's using
device orientation,
and that means it's
using the accelerometer.
So if I grab my
phone and I tip it,
you'll see the ball
starts rolling around.
So that's actually
using the accelerometer.
But you'll notice that when
I do that, down the bottom
here-- I'll just
zoom in for that,
so you can actually see it a
bit better-- where's it gone?
Oh, I fell into a hole, sorry.
So my content's actually
dynamically changed,
so I have to start
the game again.
All right.
So if I go down to the bottom
where the actual ball is,
which is here, you'll see that
as the ball is rolling around,
you can see the DOM
updating dynamically.
So it's actually
a full, live view
into the WebView content,
which is really, really
handy for debugging.
So we can do anything.
We can even edit this stuff.
So if I wanted to, I
can just come along here
and change the color
if I wanted to.
So we have black
and gray, and we
could change this to red, say.
And then all of a sudden, all
of the balls, the holes that
are in the game, change to red.
So you can do real-time, live
editing of your application
if you're using the WebView.
Now, what's really
interesting about this
is that the protocol between
the phone and the browser
is identical to desktop Chrome.
What that means is
that anything you
can do on the
desktop Chrome tools
you can do with a WebView.
So that includes
analyzing network traffic,
looking at paint times,
modifying the DOM on the fly,
all these kinds of things.
So it's a
super-powerful feature,
and I know a lot of people
have been asking for that.
OK, let's just get
rid of that one.
Ooh, all right.
Now, who here writes
Android applications?
Anybody?
I do.
No one else?
You're just here
to watch the show.
Is that right?
All right, so what
WebViews are all about
are about this new
breed of application,
like a hybrid application.
So rather than building
a mobile website,
we're building a real
Android application,
but using web technology
inside, and that's
why we call them hybrid.
But one of the things that
is really important I'd
like to point out-- if you
decide to use the Chrome
WebView in an application,
what you should do
is integrate with the
native components as well.
So before we heard all about
the ActionBar and the Navigation
Drawer and all of
these components.
We highly recommend you use
those in your application.
Now, the reason to do that
is that every time there
is a new release of Android,
they will automatically update.
So your application
won't go stale,
so it keeps in synchronization
with the platform.
You should keep the WebView
just for your custom content.
So if you're doing a
full page HTML5 game,
sure, just use
the WebView alone.
But if you're doing something
like a new social network
called Line App-- instead of
"what's app," "line app"--
and you want to basically sell
that to Yahoo for $40 billion,
what you do to build all
the framework and the menus
and everything using
native Android controls,
and in the center, where you
have your content rectangle,
use the Chrome WebView for that.
So that's the way we like to
go about using the WebView.
So when you are actually
building a hybrid application,
times you need to talk
to the native code,
and the native
code needs to talk
to JavaScript and
the WebView model.
So we have a few
methods of doing that.
If you wanted to
talk from the WebView
out into the
native-code side, you
can add a JavaScript interface.
So there's actually
a method that
lets you put a new-method
definition in JavaScript, which
calls out into Java and
talks to the native code.
Similarly, if you want to run
JavaScript from the native side
into your WebView, you
use evaluateJavaScript.
So I'll just show you
a couple of examples
of that kind of code.
So here's an example where
we've added a new JavaScript
interface.
Can everybody read
that OK at the back?
No, yes?
I'll just-- this method.
So this addJavaScript interface
basically takes two arguments.
One is an object that defines
the methods inside it,
and the second is string, which
has been cut off on my slide,
but it's the string which
names the interface.
So that's what you will
see in the JavaScript side.
So we have samples.
If you want to
actually go online,
if you go to this
particular repository,
we have examples of code that
you can just take and copy.
So if you want to experiment
with the Chrome WebView,
just go to this GitHub
repository, grab it, modify it.
I encourage you to do that.
That's what's so good
about open-source.
OK, so that lets you
call from JavaScript
back into native code.
Now, there were a
few people over here
that use the old WebView.
One thing we did find--
building the Chrome WebView was
a very large
engineering project.
And one of the biggest
problems that we had
was the fact that
HTML has changed
in the time since
the old WebView
and now, and so there
are a lot of behaviors
in the old WebView that are
undesirable, and don't conform
to current standards.
So the WebView contains
a compatibility mode.
If you build your application
with this manifest that says,
target SDK version
19 or higher, it
will run in modern
standards mode.
If you build your application
with SDK version 18 or lower,
the WebView turns on
a lot of behaviors
that are meant to be more
compatible with older
applications, and this is purely
for backwards compatibility.
These two things that I've
singled out you should know
are not supported in any mode
currently on the WebView,
and probably never will be.
So be aware, if you use narrow
columns and single column
for controlling the layout in
your application, that's gone.
What you can do now is
use text autosizing,
which is a feature in
the Chrome WebView,
so there are
workarounds to fix this.
The other thing is, the get
default zoom and set default
zoom doesn't do
anything anymore.
So they're just stubbed out.
So if you're using
those, don't use them.
OK, so let's move
forward, and we'll
assume that you're using SDK
19 to compile your application.
This is the behavior
you're going to see.
You're going to see
a user-agent change.
So the string that your
server sees will be completely
different, and it's different
right here, right there,
where it says,
Chrome/30.0.0.0, right?
So now we actually have Chrome
in the user-agent stream.
So that means you can actually
detect from server side,
or try to detect,
what kind of WebView
is connecting to
your server, so you
can send different content back.
If you don't like the
user-agent string,
you can actually change it.
So if you want to get the
user-agent string, the default
user agent, it will
return this, and that's
this method-- get
default user agent.
If you would like to
change it to emulate
some different behavior, or to
try and get different content
back from the
server, you can do it
with the set user
agent string method.
Another change here--
these multi-threading
and thread-blocking.
This is a hugely important one.
Anybody that's currently
using the WebView
and wants to switch, you need
to pay attention right now.
OK, the current version
of the Chrome WebView
has to run on the UI
thread, all right?
So the old WebView--
it was possible to run
WebViews in background threads.
Unfortunately, that's
currently not supported.
And what will happen is, if you
switch over to the new WebView
and try to do that, your app
will do very strange things,
and be nearly
impossible to debug.
So you just cannot use it
off the main UI thread.
But if you really do want to
run things from side threads,
you can still execute into that
WebView by using this method.
There's that little code
that you run on UI thread.
So if you have a bit of a
closer look at that one,
this will actually just let
you run code in the WebView.
So from a background thread, I
can put the application logic
in that method, and it
will send it over, take
care of synchronization, and
do all the magic for you,
and it will work.
And so because of this and
the new structure of the way
WebView works on
the UI thread, you
have to take extra-special care
not to block the UI thread.
So if you send off
something in JavaScript
and decide to sleep and wait,
that's a very bad thing to do,
because your application
will become unresponsive,
and Android will
try and kill it.
Now, if you want to actually
run JavaScript off the main UI
thread, rather than just
trying to execute it,
you can call
evaluateJavaScript, and that
will run it asynchronously.
So again, that won't
block the main UI thread.
So internally, the way the
graphics work in the Chrome
WebView, there's a
compositing thread,
and there's the main UI thread.
And so the
compositing thread can
be running in the
background, doing animations,
while logic is happening
on the UI thread.
So the view itself
is multi-threaded.
OK, another thing that's
changed most people probably
don't need to worry
about too much,
but the way that URLs
are handled has changed.
When you're using
custom URL schemes,
you normally register
a callback that gets
triggered off every time
it sees the custom URL,
to try and handle it.
Now, the behavior
in the old WebView
was very loose, so it
didn't work very well
from a security point of view.
So now what happens is that
it's much stricter, which
means that all of your URLs
have to conform exactly
to the RFC, the RFC
3986, which specifies
the syntax of the URL.
And as long you use that, you'll
be able to use custom URLs.
So here's an example
of a URL handler.
So this should
override URL loading.
That method there, that's
called as a callback,
so every time you
click on a link
or try and load a resource,
this callback will be fired,
and that gives you
the opportunity
to handle your custom
URL scheme and what
it is you're trying
to achieve with it.
There are changes in the
Viewport handling as well.
A lot of people used to use
this target density DPI,
and that density DPI was
something that would tell you
what kind of screen you were on.
This is completely deprecated,
because in the modern world,
as we saw with the
other presentations,
we're dealing like
design pixels,
not in actual device pixels.
PX is not really
used, so a CSS pixel
corresponds to one
or two or maybe one
and a half or four
actual, real pixels.
So that's why the target density
DPI is not there anymore.
The Viewport zooms in.
This is a new behavior.
So if you said, my content is
only 100 pixels by 200 pixels,
the Chrome WebView
will automatically
scale it to fill the
screen, so that you
don't have black borders
around the edge, or something.
Multiple Viewport tags
are not supported,
so people who are web developers
use this meta Viewport equals
blah, blah, blah
with this device
with-- there's a
whole lot of tags
to control how the Viewport
behaves, whether zooming works.
In the old WebView, way you
could put two or three of these
in with different values,
and they would concatenate--
put all the values together,
and use the union of them.
In the new WebView,
it's only the last one
that is actually used,
so be careful if you
have existing content.
And the default zoom, as I
said before, is deprecated.
So let's just see.
Oh, styling-- this is
an important one, too.
So the way CSS works-- there's
a minor change in that shorthand
CSS can override explicit CSS.
So if you see this
top example, we're
setting the background
size to contain, and then
the background to a URL of
an image with no-repeat.
Now, that second
lined background
is using CSS shorthand,
which is a way
to combine multiple
things in one line.
The problem is, that
overrides the initial setting
of background size above it.
So it's a very
simple workaround is
to flip those two lines around.
So these are only
minor, little tweaks,
but you need to
be aware of them.
Now, this is probably
the biggest change,
and I think this
is just generally
how Android and
the world is going.
But pixel densities on
screens are increasing,
so as designers,
people want to actually
design to a physical
look not to shrink.
If you have a super-high-res
screen, and then
your tap targets are
impossible to touch.
So in the old view, window outer
width and window outer height
were actual device pixels.
Now they're CSS pixels.
And if you really want
to know how many pixels
per physical pixel, you can
use window.devicepixelratio.
If you don't want to do it from
your actual extra HTML content,
you can do it from
JavaScript, or you
can do it from Java even.
You can create
something like this.
You can create an interface
that you register.
If you registered
this interface, then
from JavaScript,
you could implement
your own get-scale method in
native code that would then
go off and probe the WebView
object and return the scaling.
OK, so that's most
of what I wanted
to cover as far as how things
are going with the WebView
and how you need to use it.
There's a lot of
documentation online.
But there are three
key takeaways here.
If you want to build a
really great web-based hybrid
application, number one, always
set your SDK version to 19.
But I think that that's become
a general Android thing now.
We're seeing rapid
adoption of KitKat.
And also, one thing I don't
know if any of the sessions
will be covering it
here, but we spent
a lot of time, when
we developed Android
4.4, to reduce the
memory footprint.
Now, the reason we did
that is so that we'll
run on phones with less memory.
So we expect that
over the longer term,
Android 2.3 will just
disappear, because that category
of phone with low memory is
now capable of running KitKat.
So moving forward,
definitely use SDK 19.
Turn on hardware acceleration.
It's become crucial to a
smooth user experience.
So that applies for general
Android applications
as well, especially
on the Chrome WebView.
In fact, I think there's
approximately a factor
of 10 difference
in render speed.
If you turn off hardware
acceleration on the Chrome
WebView, and you have
graphics-intensive stuff
or Canvas or anything
like that, you'll
see that factor of 10 times
difference in performance.
And of course, enable debugging.
It's crucially important to
make sure that you can actually
debug the content that you have,
because if you can't debug it,
it's a pain in the neck,
and you waste lots of time.
So one of the best new features
we have is this debugging.
And if you want to, you
can make that conditional.
Turn it off in your
released application,
or have it as a
setting that you can
change if someone wants to debug
something out in the field.
But highly encourage you
to turn debugging on.
And so, of course,
since that's about it,
we always have to
talk about tomorrow.
And what's tomorrow?
I can confirm today that
WebRTC is definitely
coming to the next version
of the Chrome WebView.
So if you are building
WebRTC-enabled applications,
we see this as a
real game changer.
It's just democratizing
communication.
It's proper peer-to-peer
video conferencing,
data channels, everything.
It's just been turned on for
the current, in-development
WebView, and it will
be coming very soon.
So the next release of Android,
you can expect to see WebRTC.
I think last time we were
here, and probably everybody I
talk to about the
WebView is, why no WebGL?
Why no WebGL?
I don't have a good answer.
The simplest answer is simply
a graphics-architecture issue.
So as I said before, we pulled
the whole graphics back end out
of Chrome, and replaced
it with interface
directly into the
Android subsystem.
So there are design and
engineering challenges
to actually make WebGL work
with decent performance
in the WebView.
But we're certainly thinking
about it quite a lot.
And the other thing that we
have been talking about doing--
and we're still trying to
work out how we could maybe
do this-- is the idea of making
the WebView automatically
update.
So the current
WebView, as I said,
is Chrome 30, effectively.
We would like to
be able to update
the WebView in synchronization
with Chrome, so we have
an automatic-update
mechanism, but there
are a lot of
engineering challenges
to making that
work successfully.
So keep tuned, and come
to the next summit,
and we'll talk all about what
comes between now and then.
So anyway, on that note, I open
the floor to some questions.
Here are some resources,
so those two short links.
There's documentation on
the WebView on the left,
on the new WebView, and a
migration guide on the right.
So if you're a
current WebView user,
open the one on the right.
The samples that are
on GitHub-- here's
just a convenient,
short link to them
if you want to get to them.
In that case, thank
you very much.
Thanks for listening.
Thanks for having
me back in Seoul.
It's great to be
here, and I hope
to talk to you during the day.
[APPLAUSE]